look at this goddess to my left I am
standing with none other than sold you
out here looking like Rihanna at the Met
Gala I was gonna say hi I'm Rihanna
no hello everybody I'm Soulja from
season 11 of RuPaul's Drag Race here a
cake on girl
you look stunning I mean I am one of the
only drag queens here that are invited
to perform and hosts and do the panel so
I had to pull you know all the stops
I think they bailed it out I mean look
at this train I don't know if you guys
will be able to get it put on it go this
is very heavy and what did I say we were
standing here I was like I'm glad we're
standing because I want to show off my
outfit you you sure you gonna pose okay
you better go tell me how to well first
you got to know your angle right you
know okay straight forward ever
don't hang go and look a little sassy
like what are you looking at I'm doing a
little Pao is that like to my light is
here your lights over here oh yeah yeah
yeah now I'm blind I'm blinded by your
beauty I mean how's it feel to be here
at kcon and also like you said you're
the only drag queen that was invited
here they're all extra special yes I
mean you know more and more the LGBTQ
community is getting the representation
that they well deserve I mean we have
such a long journey but for them to
invite you know a Korean brand to invite
you know a drag queen to event like this
it's just an amazing feeling it's my
first year hosting and performing and
everything and the support and the love
I'm getting it's incredible I mean it
says a lot about not only your impact
but also RuPaul's Drag Race impact right
oh yeah for sure I mean RuPaul's Drag
Race is what got me into mainstream you
know media and you know I am the kpop
type princess so you know I represent
yes you do
what does that mean to you though to
represent your culture on such a
mainstream platform it's all about
representation for me you know I want to
I want to represent the queer Asian
community because you know Asian people
are not represented but a queer Asian
people are definitely underrepresented
in media so that's what I want to keep
pushing myself keep putting my face out
there and show up because you know
that's what we need to do that's
how would you say being a queer Asian
has really um how have you used that in
your art because it was very apparent
even for one episode of drag race that
your quota your culture was injected and
everything that you do yeah yeah yeah I
mean my whole artistry is based around
my Korean culture I am a Korean American
proudly and you know even if I'm doing
the whole Rihanna look I wanted to throw
in some you know traditional Korean hair
and hair pieces I love you know mixing
cultures together but at the end of the
day my Korean this is always gonna show
out how would you say that being on drag
race has changed your life I mean look
where I am launched my career I already
had like a YouTube channel before but
obviously drag race has brought me into
a platform where you know I can show my
artistry in such a bigger venues yeah
like this so it's an amazing feeling
I got to know because obviously we're
anxiously waiting for this next season
of drag race um what would you tell
people who are joining the show you know
what did you learn from that experience
that you want to share with people who
want to be on that show oh people who
want to be on drag race Joe no it's a
lot of work it's a big it's a long
journey yeah you know so I'll save up
your money and make sure you get some
time off of work if you get on because
it's gonna be a long journey it's a long
journey wit if you would you ever be on
it again if they had you come back on
the show oh yeah I mean like I feel like
my drag has changed so much season since
my season I look back and I'm like
cringing you know my makeup sstrange my
looks have changed I am your silhouette
has Shane I mean okay the silhouette for
the guys yeah I mean I would love to
come back if they ask me we but you
would be down yeah I love it
um so you release fall in love again
this summer tell people about the music
we want to hear more well you know I
recently got a boyfriend I was just
inspired to write about love yeah and
you know being a queer Asian it was
really important for me to you know
write about authentic you know
experiences of society if fall in love
again it's about falling in love for the
second time after
your first heartbreak and it's just a
beautiful thing and I'm still in love
yeah girl
maybe I'll release another single I'm
still here and I'm still loving oh but
we love love songs ah I also love your
web series though oh oh oh I got it so
good I got a no because obviously it's
called I want to be a kpop idol yeah
what does it take to be a kpop idol hard
work dedication you know you need to be
able to sacrifice a lot of lot of your
lives you know to dedicate all into
being a kpop idol but most importantly
for me it's like not just a kpop idol
but a queer artist a drag queen that is
also capable of breaking boundaries you
know that's what it is who do you stand
in the kpop world it's happening I send
black pink obviously BTS Luna um you
know the old school girls to like Girls
Generation you know 21 obviously CL my
girl Tiffany yeah I love her oh my god
the all queens and kings of what they do
of what they do you're a queen of what
you do before I let you go what's next
for soju well you know I'm gonna keep
releasing music I just released soju
bomb which is all in Korean I'm working
without a Korean producers now but you
know I'm gonna keep releasing music I'm
gonna travel the world with my kpop
party which is called Soul Train kaepa
party
make sure you guys you know check to my
website shot with so just calm gonna
plug it and let me where I'll be okay I
love it
obviously you guys can hear from all the
noise it is so insane here at kcon the
offer means so true I'll but really the
wit foot
what's the secret to surviving kcon I
know you have a survival yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay well you know I brought
out my bag my blonde see aha oh okay
designer yes I I mean most importantly
here I pulled out my little hat because
you know this very can I put this on you
oh my god if you squeeze this the ear
moves
oh my god you gotta say cute but you
know if your makeup is running that you
also gotta you know check your makeup so
make sure you check back with you
stay hydrated y'all load up you know the
male idols we're thirsty so
always always say hydrate I would say
one more thing is you know make sure
that you bring your knives camera
because you know when you want to take
pictures you don't want to you know have
those like Nancy picture well get a one
thing for on cheap pictures you want the
DSLR okay you got to get it for the
grand and it's gotta be good quality of
am i am i a kpop idol yet mom you're
getting there
[Music]